[Music]
20:17 IMI's brought out Hollywood's
biggest stars on the small screen Sunday
night this is the second Emmy winning
second nomination for Sterling K Brown
I'm an infant fairy land is something
you don't say like I still can't believe
it of course after the show it's the
after-party and et is giving you an
inside look at the exclusive soirees the
big little lies cast celebrated their
win with a night out at HBO's reception
it's the first thing you're gonna do
when you get inside to celebrate just
take my kids
Reese Witherspoon and Laura Dern party
with their kids in tow
while nicole kidman packed on the PDA
with husband Keith Urban and eye witness
tells ET Keith couldn't stop looking at
his wife in adoration another couple
enjoying a date night Ben Affleck
stepping out to support his girlfriend
SNL producer Lindsay shook Asst well
it's an on-screen daddy-daughter night
out for Kristi Metz and Milo Ventimiglia
at 20th Century Fox's bash this is us
co-stars appeared to live it up after
Stirling came Browns big win I tried to
vote for him like a proud parent in a
way so meanwhile the women of Modern
Family made some quick changes before
arriving to the same party julie bowen
pulled out this yellow number I was like
children changing a car just like a
young person and Sarah Hyland suffered a
wardrobe malfunction my dress broke in
the car over here was two-time Emmy
winner Donald Glover did not miss a beat
first joining host Stephen Colbert at
the Governor's Ball where each he
spotted Donald in line to get his new
hardware engraved
then he hit up the Fox party who did you
catch eyes with and you're like I have
officially really made it I tried to not
look at Oprah directly in the eyes
because then I feel like either her
power will overwhelm me and back at the
Governor's Ball Sarah Paulson is all of
us after a long night here she is
kicking off her heels after grabbing a
cocktail at the bar with Jessica Lange
and an insider tells ET the true life of
the party was James Corden who started a
train around the dance floor
[Music]